just a reminder that if you want to get
on your nickname should be name and
location or location and name some
combination of that for example Evan
from Las Vegas Evan from Las Vegas
welcome to the program
thank you can you hear me okay yes I can
thanks for taking my call I had a
question just
like when Trump first kind of rose to
power in 2015 it felt like it was going
to be like a crazy moment in history
that we would look back on and kind of
laugh and now that's really become the
base of the Republican party this
misinformation and kind of willful
ignorance do you see that like changing
or like how will we look back on this
time in history listen I the question of
how will we look back on this time in
history is one of those that you ask a
hundred people you'll get a hundred
different answers nobody has any clue
you know imagining how the future will
retrospectively I I could give you some
guess but I really have no idea My Hope
Is My Hope Is that Maga trumpism will
die with Trump and by that I don't mean
Trump's literal death necessarily but
the death of Trump's political career
because the truth is if Trump doesn't
get the nomination next year and
certainly if Trump loses the election
next year I think it's completely over
for Trump that will be the end of trump
and then we will have to see what
happens to Mega trumpism does it get
rejected by the Republican Party does it
take over the Republican party or does
it get integrated into the Republican
Party sort of like the way tea party
ideology uh was integrated My Hope Is
that Mega trumpism dies with the death
of Trump's political career be it in 20
in November of 24 or in January of 29
when the next president would be
inaugurated and that at that point we
get back to something being a marginally
more sane Republican party and that
history will look at it as an aberration
that's my hope I don't know that that's
the way it's going to go
yeah I definitely definitely share that
hope
um I had one other brief question I
heard you mention recently that you're
going to be in Santa Cruz California
which is my alma mater can I ask what
you're up to there oh yeah I'm going out
there for a wedding and it's the Santa
Cruz area it's not it's not actually
Santa Cruz but it's the Santa Cruz area
oh okay I say I wasn't sure if you're
maybe doing a speaking engagement at the
University or something like that no no
no but so what's the is downtown Santa
Cruz worth checking out I was doing some
street view sort of it's it's sort of
unclear to me what's going on down there
yeah you know I haven't been I've been
like in the last probably a year or two
and I I love it it's just kind of like a
chill Beach town you know there's some
some cool record stores you know
breweries and uh if you want to get a
bagel there's this place called The
Bagelry that has pretty good bagels and
locks I know you're a fan yeah yeah and
is the is the salmon co cold smoked do
you know
uh you know I I don't I don't know that
but I'll see if I can make a call and
find out yeah yeah you know I'm a I'm a
Jewish ethnicity so I I like to think I
have decent standards for for my Nova
locks and uh I think it's decent are you
for scallions or chives in cream cheese
uh I I could go either way I guess if I
had to pick I'd probably go chives oh
dear God okay all right I'm Gonna Let
You Go all right oh no I'm scallion all
the way all right all right thank you no
I'll report back about Santa Cruz
cool all right take care there we go
folks big time Big Time stuff let's take
a very quick break don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones in
a moment